اسرائيل تخطط لحبل مع ايران من دوله لدوله
هذه المره عبره تنفيذ خطتين الاولى بضربه
موجهه الى برنامج ايراد النووي والثانيه
عبر حرب مباشره مع الحرس الثوري الايراني
في التفاصيل انشات اسرائيل وحده جديده في
الاستخبارات العسكريه الاسرائيليه وهي
وحده معروفه باسم 54 وهذا الفرع الحديث لم
يحصل حتى الساعه على اثمن رسم البعد
ويتشكل مشاهدينا من 30 فردا بين ضباط
وجنود مهمه هؤلاء اعداد بنك الاهداف في
ايران لشن حرب محتمله ودراسه ومتابعه قوات
الحرس الثوري الايراني اسرائيل اقدمت ايضا
على هذه الخطه بعدما وصلت لنتيجه مفاد هذه
النتيجه بان اي مواجهه مستقبليه مع ايران
ستكون في الاغلب مواجهه في على اكثر من
جبهه والحرب قد تكون حرب استنزاف تستمر
لايام طويله
بالبناء التحتيه طبعا للطرفين لكن فشل
المحادثات حول الايراني حول النووي
الايراني والتطورات المتسارعه في ذات
البرنامج والانتقال بالحديث عن قرب ايران
من امتلاكها قنبله نوويه من سنوات الى
اسابيع قليله او ربما ايام هذا الامر
بالذات سرع في خطه اسرائيل الحربيه
المباشره مع ايران التي تمتلك اسلحه
متطوره مثل طبعا المسيرات وصواريخ كروز
وصواريخ فرض صوتيه التي يصل مداها الى عمق
تل ابيب لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات